what is up everyone it's adam ak here
for anime abroad welcome to another
episode of rant cafe episode 28 if i am
correct and in this episode we're going
to be talking about the upcoming summer
2017 anime season what we should be
watching what you should be watching
well you shouldn't be watching doc out
of stuff i personally am really looking
for some advice in the chat from the
people here we got anime recon and brynn
for its fandoms with us right now and
perhaps masculine and other people
joining soon but i'm looking for a
device because i haven't spent much time
looking into the next season so i want
you guys to tell me in the chat and here
in the stream what i should be watching
other than that ballroom dancing anime
i'm not gonna I am learning salsa I'm
still not gonna watch rude rude
the throne shade already we haven't even
started and you're already hatin I'm a
ballroom anime of course the greatest
anime of all time is still going to be
airing in the summer my hero academia
yeah I'm actually glad it's longer than
a season one yeah are you yeah I'm glad
you're glad
hi I'm everybody's gladion no comment on
boku no pico okay um so recon let's
start with you because if you guys don't
know recon on his channel does a lot of
seasonal anime he does live reaction so
he's very well informed also but before
he does however if you're new to this
channel which you might be because we
have insane growth in the last week I
think we grew by like 1500 subscribers
or something insane like that
unprecedented then basically what this
is it is a weekly podcast that we have
anime podcast on this channel every
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
where we have awesome youtubers as
guests and we talk about all things
anime and chat with you guys in the chat
and now that I've gotten that out of the
way recon taken away what anime are you
looking forward to in this season
alright so here's some recommendations
that I think
are going to be the best for summer
animate 2017 so first thing that
definitely caught my eye is by studio
you foldable is token ranbu
so this anime is by affordable we all
know affordable they do fantastic
animation but for the series there is
actually like some sort of an adaptation
and it says other I have watched that
anime it's called too can ramble on
Amato you do not necessarily have to
watch it but I still do recommend you
just to get to know the characters a
little bit more because I have a great
understanding of the characters I know
the mole so I'm super super ready for
the show body photo I cannot wait it's
basically like a samurai anime it's
gonna have tons and tons of action I'm
super excited so that's something that's
something I recommend you to watch anime
can bring if you're a fan of samurai
anime that is I am I am so that's a good
recommendation that is really good brand
you want to say um I feel like wasn't
there a token ranbu
like two seasons ago was they estate
that off this game like the video yes it
is a video game that what I already said
that it was called two can drum boo
honimaru it's it's nothing related to
what's coming in the next season but
it's just you know generally understand
the characters it's gonna be completely
different because it was based on it
wasn't any action in it not much action
but affordable this time we'll do action
so a lot of people have been telling me
that so look forward to it that's good
that's good as awesome Britney single
you forward do before we get more recon
recommendations because like I said
recon knows has seasonal anime knows the
stuff but for sure first of all I want
to point out that my ballroom anime is
happening
I saw a promotional video for it I am
excited but I do feel like they are
trying to like pull on that urea and I
strain a little bit like trying to do a
sports anime that's like a drama because
in the description it says that it's a
comedy drama romance sports sports at
the end I'm putting that as like it's
basically a drama that's got what I'm
going to sue but I'm looking forward to
it
yeah it would be funny if it was like
super heterosexual though oh okay
I'm looking to go is this from a mom I
don't know manga readers enjoyed and
well I'll give it a go
I've not heard anything about it Feeny
yeah I've only seen the perusal video
but I haven't like heard you're right
whether the manga was good or not or but
I'm excited to try it because they look
beautiful dancing and whoo
I've been waiting for a dancing anime
like other than like a magical girl like
you know that kind of dancing like an
actual ballroom dancing sport so let's
do it
such high ambitions ballroom dancing
anime you have the dance of the sweat
you have the you know intensity it is
good I can't even I can't even you know
but let me shout out a few people in the
chat I saw docstoc who over there in the
chat what's up bro
creep Ellen zero Dark Knight AKA bash
nick victory fire soul maka ryan foo
ryan foo what's up spook a neogeo a lot
of familiar plate faces we got Philly
Superman I own a Papa I'm Titan draw
Ruben is the friend killer at Luna of
course Luna is here so y'all welcome
everybody Riku I see him as well
welcome to rent café where we chill and
talk about anime by wet if I don't lay
I'm gonna be rapping soon so that's the
thing that's the thing that's gonna
happen on this channel don't unsubscribe
until you're really gonna rounder it
because you listen [ __ ] then you're
really gonna rap oh I am yeah it's gonna
be a rap skit a part of which was filmed
at anime North last weekend was anime
art it was such so much fun you guys
missed out you guys missed out huge you
said you were gonna do videos where were
the videos I wanted to see them
yeah we're editing the vlog now it's
just putting out a lot of other videos
so we have at the time we're editing the
vlog now for the longest coming for
anime north also a skip is gonna be
coming once we film everything we film
parts at enemy North it's gonna be
awesome and yeah we had a great time
minima north we uh we played this thing
called archery tag where Briggs and I
and our group beat goes in and Mac and
vector and their group so that was
excellent it was like Donny's game
except this time the good guys want
Oh interesting
okay okay I don't know what that means I
just wanted to like refused everyone but
we got back to you and we all have the
list up here on my my name a list they
have up scheduled over there for all the
new upcoming anime let me know sorry
you're looking forward to em guys in the
chat let me know what anime you are
looking for to what enemy you recommend
to me and to the rest of us here feel
free recog oh okay
this is probably gonna be the stupidest
one but but there is this anime that's
gonna air in summer 2017 is by a company
that I have never heard of in my life
called creators and pack Tokyo and it's
called
Nestle's old trap and it's base of a
whole manga and it is gonna be a ute
anime we need some urea no it's never so
yeah I've read it I've seen the trailer
I was like what the [ __ ]
so it's about these two girls who got
boyfriend's and they're like okay you
know what we're not really interested in
them but later on they find out that
those two girls are interested in each
other so yeah it's gonna be a uni anime
and I'm like what a twist
what is shocking I'm probably gonna
watch on their side I'm not gonna react
to it because it's probably gonna be not
the best anime in life like I know it's
like how can they come up with these yes
it's like it's like wow it's just so so
unique and definitely not just you're a
nice book for girls anyway it's never
even heard of it mas Melinda Garcia and
mob king in the chat I see that rod in
the sport of it what's up bro he says
that he recommends rage of Baca moot
virgin soul and I've heard of
good things about this minimized all
have I been watching it even though I
heard a lot of good things so I look
like looks like I have to take this an
amount because it's airing this season
too right yeah that's the second season
is going this season so the person was
already aired but then the second season
and it's continuing on to you know next
yeah and a soul says no game no life
zero
I really dislike no game no life I
thought are you [ __ ] kidding me are
you kidding me what's good oq Anna Mac
so [ __ ] you how dare you dislike no game
no life no game no life guys was
terrible it was just Wally bait Emoto
bait and exactly the fans are in smoke
in your face it was not fun class silly
you know like kill a kill the fanservice
is classy it has a purpose and it was so
contrived in no game no life and not to
mention the fact that the two siblings
are just deus ex machina anything that
happens
they've already predicted it they can't
possibly lose because they see
everything till 8 steps ahead of not
only the people in the anime but also in
the audience so it's like no matter what
happens you know they're gonna win it's
just not a good animega did you watch it
all yes I did I watched the whole first
season uh do you want to start a war
with me you will lose to that war look
at my lead you won't even know it look
[ __ ] you I know and here's my line your
recon getting butthurt and triggered
because no game no life okay what's it
like oh I don't know is did someone
think that did someone think that no
game no life wasn't a good animated I
miss something important here
it adamak right here says it someone
anime I mean Anna Mac says a lot of
things are bad that aren't actually bad
so I mean I wouldn't I wouldn't take it
to heart
mr. recon but uh yeah this is
unacceptable
oh maybe and I couldn't make a dog I
mean is you looking at an eye on a Mac
you make him a medivac fighters released
from vents
Anna Mac speaks the truth and that's why
the fans respect him and love him know
they don't respect you said that I don't
respect you because I said that Bush
what name name a good thing about Nuria
no life fan service it's not even well
done you know what is good I liked it
little did kill a kill is good
fanservice Keijo is if answerest killa
kill is good Keijo is good I advise my
isolated but fanservice I say is good
fanservice
I enjoyed the current I'll give you that
I put the eggs II definitely better
fencer is the no game no life I know but
still I enjoyed no game no life it was
funny was entertaining I liked it
there's a lot of there were a lot of
interesting blots and twists also
happening I mean you can't say it was
[ __ ] it was you can't say it was bad I
mean I know people have different
opinions but come on it's such a popular
show and yet they're making a movie
because they every time we thought there
will be another season ok another season
will come just be patient boom all of a
sudden they announced the movie and I
was like [ __ ] you boys now that being
said like ready battle cry out like that
but no I see some people in the chat
disagreeing with me and that's the only
fine you can absolutely disagree with me
this is just my opinion I haven't a
thing my opinion is the correct one like
you have the right to have your opinion
it's just that yeah there's I mean just
because it's popular Rican doesn't mean
that it's good I really don't think that
it's just escapism it's just like
self-insert Oh what if I you know we
went to this fantasy world and was the
Pope most powerful there for no
particular reason and yeah and now I'm
actually useful we were I didn't feel
like I was useful in my own world like
it's just been done so many times and I
don't you know it doesn't speak to me
back tell me why I'm right do you mean
because it's your opinion and that makes
you right because yeah but I don't know
I see that's that's the thing I like the
show but I disagree with the logic that
because it's popular it's good I've seen
a lot of really popular shows really bad
ah what for example
haha you want you to say so I say oh I'm
gonna rage even more because I was a
good show
don't even say it the first staff of the
first season was pretty good don't it
don't even say it I mean I love
triggering our boy havoc cafe
but I like the show the art was super
cool it was different but it was cool
no yeah like the color scheme and stuff
the color palette in the anime was cool
but like the plot is what just was
really an issue with me because like I
said even the world is interesting the
whole gaming aspect but the game is like
think about L versus light right they're
sort of strategic chess match was so
interesting because you could be like if
you thought about you're like oh man
these guys are brilliant because they
perceive this of that with no game no
life there's so many steps ahead of the
audience because there's no way they
don't give us an opportunity to figure
out what they're doing until it's
already done
it's basically deus ex machina it's
basically just but that's besides the
point i doesn't make it a bad anime i
mean i know did it means that we didn't
watch the movie ordinal scale that might
change your mind
not yet but i do i would like to try
watching it though alright i liked one
of the SAO video games that was fun ish
was it a hollow fragment uh the first
one i played all three of them because
i'd like i bought the second one i'm
like this isn't fun anymore and i
decided to buy the newest one opening
day and for some reason I decided I
should spend 79 Canadian dollars on it
what I already knew was probably bad
head hit it I played it for an hour
guess what I haven't played since then
and so you didn't like it because it was
it was a pretty poorly made game that
being said that does mean it's a bad
anime I have other reasons for why it's
a bad anime I'm kid
I'm kidding but yeah it was I'm gonna
starburst ream you a smack no I will
tell you this right house for dresses
for me to start online photo Roja is
better than no game no life uh yeah yeah
I agree
anyway hey gorgeous not exhausted a
enemies so we go back to summer anime
yeah Mady don't jump away from that yeah
Mac do you believe do you have any
summer anime that you are looking
forward to watching this cop coming
season uh let me bring out what's coming
this summer cuz I actually have no clue
uh I prepared for this I just got back
from work so I had I only just found out
what we were talking about today uh but
basically what you do is you pull up the
my anime list schedule and just BS like
always on rent cafe I do a lot of that I
do a lot us we all do except recon mmm
he's ready even though this British I'm
ready I'm ready for next season what no
get no game no life better than Sao
animatic that doesn't sound like a very
ape and Mac thing to Seoul Sao is better
than no game no life because for all its
faults Sao like you said actually has an
interesting setup in the beginning the
first arc it is kind of interesting and
also I like the gun GaN veil arc Gundam
Oh gun veil on Lin got you said gun veil
it's gonna deal okay well whichever one
I'm not a fanboy of Sao but to me like I
said it's actually interesting because
more interesting than no game no life
because while you have overpowered
characters in both at least in sword are
online you actually have like enemies
that are hyped up and like you know the
hacker guy who created the whole world
is the enemy whereas it no game no life
they just shrubs ago we're gonna destroy
everyone and here's you know we crush
everyone at least with Kirito at least
he was a beta player in sword art online
so then when he goes into the actual
game
he's good at it already so that's an
excuse with no game no life they enter a
virtual reality at the end of the season
for a season where they don't know
nothing about the the thing that they're
playing against the creators of the game
and they still win like I don't know
where it was just my soul hurt anyway
overlords good animate that does virtual
reality so yeah watch overlord instead
oh I liked overlord I was actually
getting a season two which I'm excited
for yeah exactly I have two and um I
don't know I feel like albedo is income
in competition for best yandere um she's
not really hungry yes she is
yes she is she she's she's not the kind
of younger that would kill the play she
doesn't she doesn't kill I haven't seen
her kill than the series but she's
obsessed with God and she also she's
willing to kill for the person she loves
at the drama so that's what makes
Raymond okay looking through some of the
summer anime here
here's another recommendation for me
probably it's gonna be the best this
season and comedy romance wise has he
met a new guy it's a romance comedy it's
basically about this guy who's an
unpopular person in school and he's
really he's talking about he wants to
lose his virginity so he meets this girl
I think it's gonna be a good show so
jumbles just I'm just like region
because if I reading the description I'm
just like hell yeah this is my type of
so it sounds like it it does it sounds
like it yeah a guy wanting to lose his
virginity oh please
please love me love me uh so there's
some stuff that looks interesting
oh look it's it's not free 0g you can
rise with free it's free it looks like
old ivory
it's another degree it's another gay
swimming animation it's it's free 2.0
first of all free is not a gay okay it's
a bromance
I don't do you CLE enjoy watching boys
swimming together yeah well you can have
an anime geared towards girls recog owes
us a means they're in speedos so I'm
pretty sure that's geared toward the
girls saying that looked like I know
it's bad I know you're probably are you
saying it's weird of guys wear speedos
no no are you gonna bust our yard I was
gonna say black boys
well I'm pretty sure you know this it's
it's not weird to wear shoes but uh why
would why would people wear speedos it
looks weird but at the same time it's
not yeah it yeah I know I just I have no
idea what I'm saying I got a casting
quote made an abyss because and it's ma
de not unfortunately not ma I D but made
an abyss I was i I was checking out
Sloane the female otaku stream um the
other day and she was talking about how
she thinks that this looks like a cool
anime so what'd you guys think about
this which one may made in like this by
Kinema citrus adventure fantasy sci fi
its base of a manga not too keen on this
one or not I mean the characters the two
little boys up front they look really
cute and there's like a snake coming
after me at least in the little picture
right so I can looks like a chibi style
anime right so I think I can't read
Japanese
I can't you see like I don't know I
thought I might give it a go I give it a
first impressions
who knows I do think that uh oh wait no
that's the studio never mind okay
they just well there's an anime folded
right okay I found it called the
reflection from Studio theme that's
essentially my ear or cookie
I am I saw that I'm very interested I'm
very interested in it it made an abyss
kind of looks cool they all the art
style anyway kind of the it draws me in
so yeah good answer
looks very nostalgic oh yeah I made it a
bit I made an abyss
the arts are reminds me like your Ghibli
film right yes yes here's the thing now
there's this anime call by studio he
body it's comedy Sportz and it's called
Kibaki damn she io my cocoon
looks like judging from the cover looks
like students worn like some sort of a
cleaning Club it looks ridiculous like
this in OPS's says that he likes to
would be clean like he's on a soccer
team but he doesn't see tackle and head
the ball he does it all you know wearing
gloves this is reminding me of Sakamoto
this is reminding me of Sakamoto I have
no idea live it could be good for the
record Sakamoto Desco was one of the
greatest shows I have ever seen in my
entire life
just because he is a badass dude just
because he's so cool that's why it's fun
it's probably it's probably the best
anime of all time he's cool like coolest
cool cooler and coolest get it right
yeah you could theme song to you I want
to listen to it I'm sorry right I know
it by the way sir edge Lord in the chat
is recommending arrow manga sensei I
haven't even given this a chance nor do
I plan to but I will leave with you guys
to let me know if you've seen it I've
seen it I was once a mentor edge Lord
has been has been known they're mine
go ahead well Eromanga sensei has anyone
seen it do you recommend
I've seen I'm watching it really good
it's very actually cute I love the main
protagonist saga D who's the female
character she is basically like in she
likes to draw a chi you know art and
basically she has a dream with her
brother to become the greatest you know
a novel writers authors whatever it try
and make it and Ben V known yet they're
working together nice okay well the
problem I problem is guys is I don't
like lolly stuff
so when are
you have like a bunch of lolly stuff I
am very averse to that so that's why I
would like no game no life I'm not into
it with like that type of
Aramark essence' stuff I'm just not into
it man I'm into your K Jo's your
highschool of the dead
I don't like itchy just a certain type
of itchy if you know what I mean what
kind of big boobs
thank you thank you my also big other
things as well
big big one big other things what's the
other thing
okay wait now I got you I got you I
think I know what it is the other thing
in cage row guys is it the booty yes
thank you yes okay
oh by the way like a sound like a
Jeopardy answer like I'll take the booty
for 500 but we have been seeing a lot of
like comments about this scent or no
Nyami yeah what is this I want to check
it out what's it go to Miami where is
that it's basically like monster Musume
or whatever what different it's it's
like slim girl mrs. dent or and like yes
cool with like cannibal thanks not there
Oh oh my god looks like she's a girl
with horse legs oh so I am me um Iman
animation company comedy /i supernatural
it doesn't look like the type of sugar
I would watch this looks like deed I
said Sakamoto was the greatest anime of
all time very sarcastically I think this
might be the greatest anime to have ever
been conceived the thought of it I mean
it's no no probably the greatest [ __ ] I
mean that's it I could definitely tell
that the blondie is I don't know what
kind of an animal she is but they all
have tails for sure the very one on the
right is a devil definitely and the
middle is a cent or I don't have no idea
what the blondie is probably like a
bunny rabbit well to be fair guys we
were just talking about big booties and
it doesn't get much bigger than a cent
or so
we're on the right track here this
reminds me of Santeria from Monster
those of me
she was probably best girl for me mm-hmm
I guess you like big butts as well recon
I think you have to accept it
oh no I'll go for sue actually the the
slimy one I'll go for side away in no
clothes in the chat we have a surprise
for you bro look out for the anime North
vlog you might enjoy it quite a bit
working on that now but yeah like I'm
scrolling to the list of the new summer
27 there's so much more stuff guys so
much boy there is a lot like this is the
thing this is problematic
what never problematic look at means you
can catch up on the classics yep yeah
well good things prevented is just like
the new animes is just like 80% boy cute
girls doing cute things type anime likes
not really yeah uh so many people have
been saying about a wad I'm one of a
party I have not watched any of them so
I'm not watching done I need to start I
have from what I saw like it was awesome
uh like that I started watching the
first one and I have a friend who's
diehard about it I've seen some of the
trailer stuff from some of the new ones
and like the movie it looks insane so I
need to I need to any do but I'm not got
on o new game is getting a second season
have you watched new game anyone no it's
pretty good show is about group of girls
doing cute stuff making a video game
whoa
video games I'm looking at my anime
lists scheduled for summer 2017 guys a
couple people that job we're asking what
we're looking at one show that looks
cool like actually has good animation
and looks mature is this Vatican kissaki
Chaka Khan show which looks like it's
about like Vatican conspiracies and
experiments and stuff like that so that
looks mystery mystery Superman looks
like a mystery
member be fun
who left the lid off of the holy water a
lot in dirt on the next exciting oh that
is Academy and this is probably gonna be
the greatest fete a fait anime fate um
Apocrypha am i saying this correctly no
one is safe
Apocrypha Apocrypha how do you pronounce
that Adamek do you know how to pronounce
that apocryphal or Apocrypha it's not
even a Japanese word no one can
pronounce it it's probably Greek I would
say it's a great girl
words like it's actually pronounced fate
/ stay just for the afternoon and then
you need to leave okay but anyways I
don't think I don't think if I mean I've
watched the fade series I don't think
people have to watch the the fade series
because it doesn't prop it doesn't look
like it ties to any other fate series so
it's probably an original yeah it's true
in third expert you know your characters
are different a lot of the fates series
are self-contained it's not all right
you could watch like fade 0r without
even watching fate/stay night or the
other way around even though they tie
into each other you could theoretically
not watch both because they have their
own kind of beginnings and endings so
yeah this looks interesting the fade
series has been um really popular lately
it has been uh had the games coming out
right FADEC stella and stuff so I think
I'll give this one a watch for sure
because again at least it's you know I'm
not a completely moy animation anime I'm
getting tired of the of the home boy
saying obviously there's a more anime
that's really good I will give it a
chance but usually they're not they're
just you don't just all look so cute so
cute
Saku googles when anime thinks when he
looks the mirror it looks so cute yeah I
know I see nothing there I don't need to
see a bunch of other Hawaii you know you
don't want to see cute girls I don't
understand what are you saying well yeah
like I don't want to see girls I want to
see like Ville up
girls that's what I'm oh okay
moms I'm really awesome yeah that's
that's a voice that I do
how are you this one cafe ladies and
gentlemen looks like a dubbing anime boy
to loosen by Lydon films it's a drama
and romance one I don't know the I think
the animation kinda reminds me of um
Kizuna Han Chi if you guys look at it
hmm
it's quite elusive by light in films
kinda reminds me cuz wrong yeah it's
basically mangas well so difficult Rama
romance I'll definitely give it a goal
oh so there's an actual plot in this one
it says we're young people in Japan turn
16 they're assigned a marriage partner
by the government cover who okay my dear
seeds speak with us Hong Kong's really
something right speaking of Cousineau
honk I do you guys enjoy it I started
watching it it made me really sad and I
stopped watching you felt sound I wanted
watch it but I have not started yet
it is so I mean I've watched it I I mean
I've looked at some comments so many
people were complaining people were
saying it is [ __ ] it is bad as you keep
on progressing through episode it is
[ __ ] it is bad for me it was a decent
show wasn't the best it was a decent
show for me I mean to be honest you
could say it's from mature people
so get ready there is like we can call
this the porn I heard it's a spice I
wouldn't know I wouldn't say it's pleura
it touches on some more mature subject
matter than it would it's it's for its
for a more mature audience
it is from drawings you touch it there
is beauty in it I'm not I'm telling you
right now there is Yuri in it uh so yeah
well now I know it's gonna happen so I
think enjoy enjoy the ride I mean adamak
you'll definitely like who's a long time
don't you I haven't seen it
i watch it go ahead we might be
disappointed them Oh
caca guru II we haven't talked about
this so I think it's like about an elite
school where they gamble a lot instead
of study that was one that I was
actually gonna bring up at some point
cuz um the idea reminds me of death
parade like when you lose something that
you like I'm thinking like morbid like
death parade when you like lose limbs
and body parts and things like that but
I know it's like that but it says
psychological so that could be a twisty
I don't know maybe people are gonna die
there's a whole butt ton of characters
on that poster there I doubt I'm gonna
remember all their names right just if
they're just gonna die don't tell me
their names because I won't remember how
like everyone I do not want another
dangan ronpa series at all we've had too
many killing anime series too many fairy
tale 2017 says look at Kurt no naka baka
dawa no beshte where is this have you
watched it have you watched it on Dragon
have you watched the new fairytail the
movie no I've I only watched like a
perfect the episodes of fairytale
Islands thought I'd go watch Fairy Tail
on you guys just you're not keeping up
with a good anime I'm disappointed so I
don't know man I just I like my anime to
switch it up instead of just what do you
really want peace or Naruto neither okay
okay so so this skirt anime looks very
yurid which Mary Jo strong Eureka go
find it
which one what is it called the skirt
nanaka walk got the model - that's like
two chicks embracing each other what to
her looking chicks at least this is the
one that I talked about the one that has
UT migrators impact Tokyo also another
one that I saw the looks kind of green
is where is it
did I see G Connell shush I sha Zhi wait
all right you come musa hi Sasha
okay but photo by project nine base of a
manga time eating demons your tiny
basically basically when someone wishes
to turn back time which I know people do
all the time
a demon appears and then these guys to
try to grant them their wish for a price
of course and then these people are
fight against those demons in order to
stop the time-space continuum from going
crazy right off loading so that sounds
good I feel like I'm not that I don't
know what it looks like like look wise
but based on that synapses that probably
not my enemy with because it keeps
crashing on me I need a I need a
computer I know why Charlie Mac use any
chart yeah the thousands of people that
are watching Grand Cafe right now all
went on the same time and it crashed and
crashed thousands ^ brand cafes
oh I feel like there's one more that I
saw that we haven't mentioned oh yes I I
too remember one that I did mention up
Kobe knee karashi spy studio Perea
soccer video period I'm just saying it
right now they mess up every series I
hate them they're probably the worst
anime company I've ever come across
seriously they suck ass oh you should I
know that recommendation brim it has
appeared not to be almost I was actually
gonna say about the studio because they
did you own of the Don I'm always like
bitter that they're not picking it up so
I have to like watch everything that
they do cuz I'm like you could have done
Univ the Diane I love y'all know the
dollar last series that they have done
like [ __ ] divine gate was absolutely
crap
twins are twin star Exorcist they
completely messed it up I'm not lying
they completely messed it up what else
um [ __ ] last season they did like a
cop series which was [ __ ]
now they're doing this one which is a
slice-of-life anime featuring a bunch of
high school boys by me I am like nope
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
I'm out I'm not watching that I guess
bender way to kind of narrow down what
I'd be watching or either PA works or ki
students to do ki or su your trigger
making anything that's true yeah I was
gonna say there's none but PJ works but
it's Sakura quest and I don't think I've
watched your like never it is DC request
like I'm still watching it I'm actually
forcing myself to watch it I just like
PA works by the way there's a lot when
the charge is going off about Fairy Tail
other [ __ ] like I see one king over
there going crazy anime dude everybody
everybody wants to know how he got this
like everybody wants to like me there's
almost I'm just gonna say this right now
one piece of narrative suck Fairy Tail
is the [ __ ] that everybody needs to get
into I'm sorry guys this is my honest
opinion if you're if you're a bad if
you're a fan of friends coming together
fighting something that they can't be
getting utterly crushed there's no way
they can come back from it and then
magically just sort of thing like I
believe in you and then winning this
shows for you check out Finn oh my guys
check it out on recons view does not
reflect the view of red cafe as a whole
yeah little little Asterix in the corner
uh but but annoying as we were having
the stream we crossed fourteen thousand
subscribers everyone in sake insane
thank you if you're watching this if
you're new thank you for coming in and
if you're older and you've been here a
long longer thank you as well the
support means a lot and it just makes it
even more fun to argue with enemy recon
and people in the chat about no game to
life in these live streams so yeah
thanks everybody
um there's also an anime called
non-ahmadis unbox ooh and it's about
like competitive quiz shows in high
school like I don't what is it with
these niche anime like cleaning and ball
room to answer a question yeah like if
we're gonna have muy can we have like
another how do we zoom me on my where
it's actually like good hmm help me mad
Oh jack studio alert is back known for
making dumb and rumba killing enemy
they're making a comedy romance anime
it's like at the very end at any charts
called Yokoso jitter jitter uyoku Shizue
shogi no Q Shih Tzu a II yeah it is from
a light novel uh-hmm
have a freedom to wear any hairstyle
bring on the personal affect the desire
cuz it was like but the truth is most of
them specie receive favorable treatment
this madness blend the description is so
bland it doesn't tell me anything
yeah I know it's so bland did we talk
about
sake reload blast yet uh no I'm looking
forward to that my platinum vision yeah
it looks it says at last the sanzu party
has arrived in India in this foreign
land where the anomalies influence runs
rampant what's the anomaly we don't know
but I'm interested there battle only
their battles only heightened in their
violence and also waiting them is their
tragic fate from 500 years ago what will
they find at the end of their long yet
treacherous journey now this is
interesting to me because it smells oh
Journey to the West right which I read
that book it's really interesting um it
also we're looking at reincarnation
stuff from their fate from 500 years ago
we're looking at anomaly like see this
has my interest and the animation looks
cool like an actual cool action anime so
yeah something like that I would give a
chance I found and I'm sorry
people keep fun rambling about fairy
tale one piece anartha yeah I know
people are losing in the travel the
three anime that I don't even watch or
Airport watch fairy tale please just get
out
best God ever slip that noise was just
he's like I do like Arizona I know I
know many people don't like to you know
keep up with long long long anime series
but fairytale is worth it I don't I
don't know keeping up with a long series
but fairy tales kind of keeps doing the
same thing
good luck keeping up with one piece
because that is like [ __ ] 700
episodes long i-i-i i watched one
episode of one piece i saw how many
there were and i put it away
i've said no they only um we had about
nor zero recommending the king's avatar
song shiqiao soul which is I guess that
Chinese anime that people about yeah I
need to watch this and make videos about
it because everyone who makes videos
about this anime gets like 700,000 views
like freaking pedantic romantic just
like random people getting like all
these hundreds of thousands of views on
this Chinese so-called anime so I mean
almost kind of know how to get on this I
get on this type train you know on the
train thanks everyone for the congrats
on 14k means a lot I see you guys down
there and chat continue guys are pollen
I think anime needs to watch skirt no
naka waka Domino does she did yes yeah
we've met yeah this one okay as long as
it's been mentioned I just saw it and I
thought of you right away
hmm yes right you see this this Magic
Bus came together they sat around a
table they said you know who needs this
in a mag what about this this looks
interesting buy silver ring a sky
shokudo choco do izakaya shakadou by
silver link it's basically a girl
standing there with a book oh yeah a
comedy fantasy mystery for her light
novel mmm cuisine car cap cap Oh cat
restaurant oh okay okay okay it's gonna
be a [ __ ] restaurant series yeah
that's that's not
my customers for the office workers
familiy yeah it's gonna be like a
restaurant series yeah it's an echo cafe
basically by the way Eagle Eye says
assassination classroom he's asking me
I'm actually watching assassination
classroom right now at like as we speak
I see on animate it's not how I'm not
right right now but like currently and
I'm actually liking and it's quite
interesting and there's a Serbian
character you guys the first Serbian
character in anime you need a yellow
each the teacher yeah and she actually
threw P and I looked it up and I was
like yes and yes Serbian girls are that
attractive so it is accurate it is an
accurate portrayal of Serbian girls so
yeah man I'm pretty psyched about that
I'm pretty psyched she's an
international assassin second shell if
you haven't watched it michael--ah
liking that also we have here another
sword out online
clone Knights and magic a mecha otaku is
reincarnated into another world as an ST
echevarría also known as arrow of course
because that is the nickname for a guy
with a clearly Italian name in this
world huge humanoid weapons known as
silhouette Knights exist dreaming of
piloting these robots arrow and his
friends are kid altar and adult rude
altar aim to become Knight runners oh
[Music]
it's always an otaku getting a transport
into a fantasy world where he is
suddenly the most important person ever
I wonder why beautiful I will watch that
skirt anime if there is a male character
that both of those chicks are into that
I can be a that can be like a self
insert for me I would want
like one of those where you don't really
see the main character space so you can
just picture yourself there you know
what I'm I know what you say I know just
like you going [ __ ]
what are you pretty sure yeah what do
you guys think of this by production
reader it's a Kiowa smartphone to tomo
production read it's large foam I
understood that one smartphone I know I
knew that what word is this about I
speak Japanese now this is amazing it is
a very precise context a second chance
at life second chances I was it like a
resurrected it is pulling figures across
to me I'm such that if I did yeah it's
basically like a harem you could you can
see the cover of the photo it's like a
dude sitting in the chair surrounded by
girls
oh that's a lot of that's a lot of girls
boy animation right so I'm here bundle
over five two men I don't know the cover
seriously tells me this is like a
[ __ ] harems oh yeah oh yeah this is
another one this other one when a guy is
accidentally killed and God allows him
to be reborn in a fantasy world where he
has do it I own and named Aaron idly
Subaru
Surrey cell phone online cell phone
online welcome really a result on online
no life great I'm pretty sure this is
gonna be a badass anime literally this
dude gets all the girls in a fantasy
world
I'm I'm digging this I'm definitely
watching us do we have any ecchi series
this the season seriously it's like we
don't have any exit of season man all of
those like more anime are gonna have
like that you know it
I can't leave I'd NEX eat eggs at old
[ __ ] that
oh you're looking for the actual tags
yeah there is no ecchi anywhere are you
kidding me well look that skirt enemy
doesn't got she then come on cuz I mean
every time there it is there it is Oh
does it
I'm watching avatar avatars anime right
and you know you know from the panel
what'swhat's wrong Anna Mac did I did I
say something wrong they remembered the
other lady at the panel or her reaction
- yeah that was dope
we're talking with the the anime
philosophy panel that I hosted by the
way at anime North look how on the vlog
we're gonna be talking about that as
well have little bits and pieces from
that Mac was there and goes there front
row not center but thigh but front row
it was fun I was there I got signs did
you blue did you woo I would a lot I
also got some really good shots so when
you're in my vlog you're gonna look as
the kids say dope is the Pope so well I
hope so I hope there's a lot of
airbrushing I'm I think I might be
disappointed by this season because I
I'm not getting mine she you know I'm an
actual fan boy so if I don't get itchy
this season I'm gonna be pissed
well they do see this tq9 huh it's not
tagged as edgy but it looks like a lot
of edgy on the t29 but it's like the
ninth season of it nine seasons
apparently nine more seasons more t99
more seasons has not watched that much I
cannot I'm gonna watch hmm
we pretty much discussed all the good
children and all the others you know
decent man
I'm not overall super impressed though I
will say that maybe cuz I haven't heard
about a lot of these shows like I
haven't seen the promotional videos
maybe or just I haven't heard a lot of
it I'm not like shouldn't Haley's judge
them by the cover and by the description
we just just give it a go
just give it a good groove like you have
to decide which ones to give a go yeah
what give the web we're going to do is
just give them all a wash see if you
like the first episode if you don't drop
it just go to the next one yonder
funeral samurai one that you mentioned
um conquer grumble grumble yeah I'm
gonna give that a shot they shot your
grip bar above for creeper a pop I still
don't know how to pronounce it I have no
idea
I'll talk about you this gingka thing a
shot yeah are you gonna give hajimete no
guy like you reload blasts so that's
probably and maybe made an abyss like
y'all probably like look at the fruit 5
or so are you gonna watch month I'm
gonna watch but I gotta watch like whole
bunch of I even lunchable bit like I'll
catch up later people I called this
anime was really good that season you
haven't watch it then I'll watch this
for example assassination classroom now
a lot of people recommended it so that's
what I'm watching it but like I don't
necessarily always watch anime as they
come up are you gonna watch both of them
what are you gonna watch ball room the
one Bri also hyped up for no no no what
even if it gets a grin recommendation oh
especially if it get the Brin boy cute
boys doing boy things keep their
attention down like wow cute boys doing
cute things its own understand I said I
just not what I was do you need what
else did here in life about the movies
we'll see you already talked about no
given whole life there's a free movie
coming out I'm not watching that no not
many of the movies interested me OVA
specials
there's some pretty good OVS coming out
oh there is an OVA for hand shakers um
um I'm excited bad brand max remember
hand shakers oh I remember him eighties
rid Mac and I watched the first episode
of her hand shakers so that we could be
on Sinai blizzards first impressions
video and it was quite the show white
the show did you like it what would you
rate the show
well I only watched one episode so I
didn't I didn't rate it highly enough to
keep going for sure a billion out of ten
there is a billion jiggle Saturday is
Google stray dogs OVA coming on there
yeah that's excitable stray dogs OVA
there is Kobayashi OVA I'm not looking
for that Kobayashi dragon I don't know
if you guys have watched it it's a damn
good show dragon made ya Jack and me
damn boy there was a lot of good and my
cosplayers dudes cosplaying as the
dragon made at anime video areas because
it's a really good show very funny I
liked it and it's basically about this
about this girl who's a dragon Maiden
yeah but I loved it man
Luke NZ and the Chad says hello from
Serbia hey what's up man I'm from Serbia
- currently living in Canada but from
Serbia I'm actually thinking about when
I should go back and visit perhaps this
summer sometime the family and
everything so yeah that would be cool
I'm still looking into when but yeah
Scipio Serbia Wow I think I see let's
thought doesn't there's been English and
Serbian English like Serbia in Serbia
Serbia hmm fist pump yep yeah you gotta
be a mech if you call Ian whether what
God was like I think artery meters on a
Mac what sort are you caught up to
recreate errs yes I am is a good now
like the whole identity of the uniform
princess I'm liking this I'm liking this
aspect of it hmm
different do you understand what's going
on no recon of course I understand
what's going on I didn't want to spoil
it for people game but let's play what
is like it was the start was interesting
and then it was getting a little bit
like convoluted but now I like that it's
going to like actually like revealing
the purpose behind why everyone is
specifically chosen to be part of the
you know main narrative as a bull just
accidentally because that's what I don't
like when people like brought into
altogether there's no real reason it's
like over here and I'll remain
characters right I like when there's an
actual reason as to why these specific
people are our protagonists and I guys
I'm so proud of you you have made me
proud proud dad I'm part of your desk
how are you dad from now on yes you may
call in the poppy Tama and make pretty
much talk about everything but I think
it's time for me to give out okay recon
recon by the way is in England so it's
late where he is yeah it is pretty ly
but I'm only talked about everything I
shared all my information but overall
I'm excited okay well yeah like I think
usually the way it works is the winter
and summer season are slower and then
the spring and fall season are the big
guns right the big seasons hype yeah
that seemed to be how it is and you know
there's a few animated I'll definitely a
chance here there could be some you know
diamonds in the rough but I'm not like
super hyped for any of them however we
will see we will see it's not it's not
your like you know attack on Titan hype
which is just like so good like I can't
I couldn't even handle it like I'm I'm
almost caught up to the in the manga now
to the anime I was going to wait till
the anime finish is airing to read the
manga obviously my brother goes and has
it read it already twice well I was like
I can't wait anymore so I might and like
after this week I'll probably just like
go and read the whole long I can't I
can't take it anymore
what what's happening Oh Britt were you
were you laughs I don't know I'm just
laughing
Slevin LOI but it was just the less I
got a good that some quality okay so so
are you saying that I not knowing we
took off my pants again or something
again guys if this happens again
seriously for reals
for realsies and feels it's coming yeah
I mean for real it happens all the time
we just yeah like Spencer that [ __ ] out
but like with my back after dark you get
at all it's like a special the special
package if you will and can I send the
package back to the sender you'll have
to handle it and then ship it so so so
we lose either way that's it
damn do we still even pay for shipping
here we Android a bunch of zeros one is
asking if we washed
acha acha 13 and actually I haven't bran
you did right yes I did
and I think you recommend it to me
because he has politics and I like a lot
of political anime but I never got
around to watching it so Bryn talked
about it a bit so yeah it was all very
political there's like different regions
and areas and like it's so political
that you think like this is super boring
but the way they explain it and like
build the world like there's like
rebellions happening or like you know
when I try rumors of rebellion starting
I liked it a lot it's not gonna be
everyone's type of show it's got a slow
burn to it that's in the first couple of
so it's like this is a lot of talking
but then once you get into it's good
it's yeah I was really really happy with
it but yeah if you like politics should
try watching it yeah I actually really
liked Poppy's Lum King in the chat says
I'm ignoring him I don't know what
you're saying
I don't know why you need me to answer I
didn't see a question but I see you but
yeah so I love anime like attack on
Titan Code Geass legend of the Galactic
Heroes all those types banner with tons
of politics so well some of them might
think politics is boring to me that's
like yes politics military strategy that
type of stuff I'm totally into so I
might give a car shot [ __ ] but it's got
a slow burn so pre prepared to listen to
the first two episodes and be kind of
like processing processing like the
world building the world yeah just like
in your face gun thing ok ok so it's a
yeah but then it then once you
understand it right it builds it and
then it just like takes off but you
gotta have a few episodes to get there
ok I hear you I hear you
any other final thoughts guys before we
adjourn because I want to go and edit a
brand-new Code Geass video that will be
coming out tomorrow a new code yes video
coming out tomorrow on more attack on
Titan videos on the way Saturday streams
coming on Saturday twitch party on
Sunday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time so at noon Eastern Standard Time so
follow us on Twitter like in the
description um anything else in the chat
that you guys gonna dress about this
upcoming season Brin and Mac if you're
still with us out about your sneezing
over there or something that is nice and
I succeeded it was awesome
good anything else you guys are thinking
about for this upcoming season not that
I've seen I'm honestly I'm not
underwhelmed by
I'm getting there like with what's kind
of coming out I will check out that one
about Maine abyss yep that one that's
the one I'm gonna take that out and I'm
gonna check out stress about it but uh
and I'll just kind of just kind of wait
to see what people think of other stuff
I see something's picking up a bit steam
I might check it out uh I am not much
I'm just probably gonna be catching up
on classics and work and videos and all
that stuff so we'll see how she goes
yeah and re-watching Gurren Lagann
everyone needs to rewatch breath by the
way lump King he's asking about Hunter x
Hunter hunter hunter
I haven't finished Hunter hunter I
started watching it and then I stopped
after like the first season uh but I do
hear good things really good things
about Hunter hunter even for us before
like your main stream battle shown and
people say that it's actually quite good
so I'll probably end up continuing that
eventually I just got to get around to
it I know the manga is apparently coming
out of hiatus for a little bit finally
whatever hiatus crazy yes but um yeah an
alum king he just watched Gurren Lagann
recently and he thought it was amazing
as I knew he would it's a good work
man's proud of you and we also had
someone in the chat Philly Superman said
that he'd started watching Code Geass
because of this show I think he needs
red poppy but yes Cody is definitely
keep watching that stuff you know Brin
as well needs to finish Kogi us I'm
working on it alright i working on it
I'm I got 25 so I'm working my way into
the next season you know obviously you
watch the procedure what is it not
enough cute boys for your brain too many
cute girls anymore boys but no oh no it
is good how good-looking is Valletta
focus someone like come on
Valletta come on so so I still Follette
it right okay no yeah I like I like the
letter I I still like a douche
look like him ledouche I like him I'm
I'm understanding why people like him
now before I was like yeah he looks kind
of cool he looks very majestic in his
long cape but now it's like okay I
understand yeah he's very cool he's a
great character but the thing is your
when you have like a really hyped up
character and haven't seen the show
right you're kind of like ah you know is
he really all that is cracked up to be
but some characters really are and I
think Lelouch is one of those you know
spike is one of those communi like those
types scared like and an Alphonse Elric
those type of characters people you know
build them up and you're like ah are
they really that cool but then when you
actually watch it yes yes they are not
cool he is pretty cool and I'm
understanding why he's so cool now it's
good stuff but we can talk about that
more when I finish the season and finish
the entire anime sounds good I'm looking
forward to your impressions of the anime
once you finish we're gonna be talking
about that Mac what are you going to be
watching next uh well it's about the
time of year where i rewatch all of the
anime that hurts my soul so right now
I'm working on Little Busters actually
for the third time said of watching
shows that I haven't seen and then I
should catch up on uh I'm also it's I've
given Clannad quite a bit of a break and
I think it's almost time for another
round of that yeah other than that I've
started watching mushishi I love it uh
yes sure good I want you as well it's
good stuff it's really good stuff second
opening super good super good uh other
than that not too much I'll take
suggestions though I'll take all the
suggestions I can get yeah and actually
I have to rewatch command because I want
to do a video about the ending and I've
been meaning to do this but like it's
like 50 episodes to re-watch just for
that ending our pocket mind you have to
watch the whole thing because it's all
it's all foreshadowed right so I've been
putting that off but I really need to do
that sometime this summer because I
really want to do that video back oh
yeah I want you to do the video to just
don't include any of the soundtrack in
it or I can't watch your video without
feeling and I want to watch your videos
and feel that's not why I water is
nothing like I'm watching all these
peels videos
watching everything to makes me cry
makes me sad like dope no more no more
sadness no more tears
fun stuff fun stuff the feels yo the
fields are real that's why we love you
our animu um yes thank you guys for
being here today I think that's we've
covered all the bases and of course we
will keep you posted if you find some
really good summer 2017 anime that we
think you need to check out ah thank you
to Bryn Mack and an America for being
our guest this week their links are in
the description you can check them out
there their channels they are all
excellent youtubers and we appreciate
them very much and everyone in the chat
thank you guys as well for coming and
coming every week and like I said we're
here every week chatting about anime
chatting about random stuff just having
a good time good time and good people am
I right guys you're not wrong man it
can't say best time except for in cafes
a little better but brand cafes pretty
cool too
okay Bryn tell us about brink of a
possible the content that you make on
your channel well Brin cafes great place
if you come subscribe to my channel you
might see some sweet content like I'd
like to do anime reviews like to do
reviews or first impressions along with
like speed sketches to kind of vary
things up but a lot of anime on my
channel at prints fandoms if you want to
subscribe you can see that and brain
cafe potentially coming soon not really
but we can pretend though who knows who
knows who knows what I mean it's coming
yeah oh did you see her yawned in her
face oh my god that was that was that
was almost too good young that I almost
like it comes naturally bread what don't
we know about you
what are you hiding what are you hiding
Macklemore
tell us who you are what you do hi a Mac
it's been such a long day uh a Mac I do
a lot of satire a lot of skits a lot of
making you think that it's going to be
something serious and it's totally not I
also have a really really sweet a few
really sweet at my North things coming
out from the convention that we just
attended I started working on the
cosplay compilation it's almost done I'm
supposed to have it ready for Sunday and
like as soon as I started on it I was
super excited like just it's gonna be
good and then obviously the vlog is
coming shortly after the vlogs were the
real fun is cuz I got to meet Anna Mac I
got to meet Joe Joe who just got in
how's it going dude and Briggs and all
the other people and vector and spoiler
alert we play we play archery tag and I
do it in a skirt so you should
definitely check that so for myself at
checkout to see one exactly exactly
do that but if you can subscribe to me
on the youtubes I do things every Sunday
or I try I'm supposed to do things every
Sunday so go check that's outside it I
do it alright cool
sounds good by the way we had roemello
Harper suggest watching kata Kyo hitman
reborn I haven't heard of this but I
will look into it
thank you for the recommendation and
Jojo shoutout to Jody out we I met Joe
Joe talks too much and enemy North Mac
vector Maximus Briggs from old anime and
hopefully next to your bread from Bryn's
fandoms gonna be there right yes
gonna happen the in here from now I love
you food and plus it'll be my birthday
that weekend so we can like party I mean
I'm almost scared good
hang it up with alcohol I'm sorry
yes that's good that's good alright so I
think I think that when we get those
awkward silences it's a sign that
everyone's tired and do we need to call
it a day but again thank you everyone in
the chat thank everyone who was our
guest today a links are in the
description um you can
we can continue the fun chat on our
discord server you can join that link in
the description as well I'm there often
goes in sometimes shows up so you know
you might even see him and Mac and Brent
as well sometimes show up so yeah check
that out and until next time we do this
every week see uh space cowboys bang
decided